Hi, I am Kagure Kabue. I am from Kenya originally, but I live in San Francisco
now. And I lived in an area that had a high prevalence for sickle cell anaemia.
>> In Kenya, is Sickle cell anaemia a common trait?
>> I don't know how common it is, but I
do know of people who've had it, or who have it.
>> Yeah, and what are the symptoms of sickle cell anaemia, or what
was it like for these people that you know of who, who've had it?
>> It was something that I didn't
know was happening until they told me themselves.
>> Mm-hm.
>> with one person, I always thought to myself that she looked a
little sickly sometimes. But, I just thought that maybe she had a cold.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But, it turns out that she had, or has sickle cell anaemia.
>> Mm-hm, is it is it a big
deal? I mean, does it seriously affect their lives?
>> I'm not sure. I'm not sure it does. I would imagine
it does, but she's very private with it and so I don't know
how much it affected her. All in all, she seemed to function normally. or,
you know, she would show up to class and go through everything that
we would go through. And then, I'd think to myself, oh she's sick again?
>> Mm-hm, is any one known in your family,
though who has ever been affected by sickle cell anaemia?
>> No.
>> That you know.
>> No, not in my family.
>> Do you know if you're a carrier for sickle cell anaemia?
>> I do know that and I'm not.
>> That's great. does that factor net in people's decisions about
you know, children? Do people worry about that? having sickle cell anaemia.
>> I, I would imagine that in a family where it was common, where it had been
running through the family that they might consider it.
But I've never heard of people getting that test,
because with some people they know it's not, it's
more common in some tribes than it is in others.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so I think in a tribe like mine where it rarely happens
I don't see why. I don't think they'd factor in.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Sickle cell anaemia or whether they were
carriers or not into who they would marry.
>> Do you know of the treatment for sickle cell anaemia? I
mean for people who have it in Kenya? Is it generally accessible? I
mean is it able? I mean, do people know about it, is
it something that's able to be treated in general for, for most people?
>> So in a country like Kenya with
a rural population that may be less literate.
>> Mm-hm.
>> They would be less likely to know about treatment options,
than a population that was more, more urban or more literate.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Not necessarily the same thing but more literate.
>> Mm-hm. They would know more and would have
access to treatment. So it depends the region as well.